alright man so the EP it's out it's an
exciting moment for you
teenage fever like a culmination of all
of your efforts as a musician up to this
point yeah I'd say it's all been
building up at this point for like the
last eight seven years but the actual
teenage fever name is more about the
experiences that I've had and the
learning opportunities that I've been
given over the course of my teenage
years sure the last few years for you
have been crazy you experienced crazy
growth your fan base getting bigger and
bigger if you take a step back and look
at what's been happening does it like
amazed you that this is where you're at
right now yeah I I mean I just think
back on I remember how I was feeling and
what I was thinking like I remember
vividly being at 250,000 subscribers on
YouTube and just sitting my chair and
just feeling like oh my god like I'm
like a quarter way to a million and now
I'm a three million it feels surreal
like it doesn't even I don't even know
how to explain it like it all feels free
but yeah it's it's the best feeling in
the world
how's your relationship with social
media and being able to like be in
contact with your fans changed because
the volume has increased so much well
I'd say Instagram and and YouTube
comments and Twitter they're very good
tools and especially Instagram life
they're very good tools to be able to
talk to people really quickly and really
efficiently rather than you know being
closed off and like it like and how 30
years ago you had to go to a show and
like hope to see er your favorite
artists out back and maybe ask them a
question yeah yeah so it's definitely
changed it's a lot harder to answer up
to everybody now but it's still better
than it used to be yeah I mean you
wanted this for a lot of time you've
been working at it for years and years
like your whole life essentially yeah I
remember yeah so as you go into this
next phase of your career and the theme
that you're getting is it kind of like
what you expected
I mean I don't think I have any
substantial fame at the moment I don't
really know what to expect I mean you
hear what people say and then I've like
talked to people that are like actually
famous and you hear what they say and I
guess you just kind of have to average
it out right I'm not really sure what to
expect
to be honest yeah but I guess we'll
hopefully see ya what's some good advice
that someone that's been in your shoes
or like you said is famous has given you
I don't I haven't really gotten any
advice but I've kind of inferred things
and one of them is never count anybody
out because I've seen it happen over and
over and over again people just don't
learn their lesson you have to support
everybody around you even if you're
doing better than let me think you think
you're doing well you've no idea what's
gonna happen tomorrow right and there's
no way to predict that really so you
have to be kind to everyone and you have
to expect anything right let's talk
about the single sleep where did where'd
it come from where the idea come from
and why this song so sleep was I the
concept was actually created by a
Swedish writer named Linea we got to the
session you're just chilling then she
was like I have an idea
you're like all right and then she tells
us that she wants to make a song about
how you she wants to stay awake as long
as possible because every minute that
you're sleeping is a minute that you're
in a place where it couldn't possibly be
better than what's happening in the real
world right so I thought it was amazing
and like right away we're like alright
let's do it
and we wrote the song really quickly
yeah and I think that's out almost all
the best songs ever made and I think we
chose it because it just has a very it's
very danceable yeah I think and it's
kind of like a universally liked style
of music so yeah it's it's good for
everybody
it's good for everyone I think that your
dance moves are good for everyone
well the YouTube and I mean the video is
great they have you
Daiki I guess they're teaching you how
to dance I mean you got a dance like you
don't have you taught how to dance I
don't know I did dancing lessons a
couple of times when I was like I don't
know 13 yeah I think I need to be
retaught what are the perfect teachers
right yeah I guess I'm speaking of being
taught you're you're still in school
right like I'm like a regular school did
you go to send out regular
semi-regular yet so what are your peers
and friends at your school think of what
you're going through right now I don't
think they care anymore and they don't
really like you know I mean cuz it's
like the first day there are like whoa
like these kids famous whatever it sure
and then after three weeks are like oh
he's just literally a normal person
yeah that happens to have followers on
Instagram yeah I mean sorry I'm very
normal I my dad and in my family are
determined to keep me that way which is
good so yeah I think after a while they
were just like oh all right cool but
yeah the first day was definitely a
little weird there's some tension there
but I mean as you're falling grows and
obviously you're working towards bigger
things and bigger things like how long
do you think you'll be able to to stay
as like normal as possible because the
world can kind of turn upside down if
you've got a massive hit on your hands
right yeah I guess so um I guess the
only thing that's gonna change is how
hard I have to work to keep up with
everything but like I said if I get out
of hand my head gets too big my dad and
sisters will be right there to put me
back into place so that's great yeah I'm
thinking
[Music]